foreign
for the Press preview then it's the
first look at tomorrow's front pages and
tonight we'll check out the headlines
with journalist and author Christina
Patterson and the columnist at the
article Ali Mirage great to see you this
Saturday evening we'll chat in a moment
after we've had a look at some of those
front pages for you begin with the
Observer which says ministers are under
pressure to open new pay talks with
unions to avert a series of NHS strikes
pharmacies drafted in to break NHS
strike reads the fun to the Sunday
Telegraph which says chemists could be
given extra powers
the front of the Sandy mirror looks
ahead to the release of the Duke and
Duchess of sussex's Netflix documentary
its headline utterly explosive
Harry Brits need lesson reads the fun to
the son of on Sunday as they lead with
the same story
William I'll fight back reads the front
of the Sun Express as they predict
Prince William's reaction to the Netflix
documentary The Daily Star on Sunday
pictures Gary lineker on its cover as it
wishes luck to the England team in their
World Cup match against Senegal
and that story is also on the front of
the people with the headline yes we came
and we're joined by Christina Patterson
and Ali Mirage really good to see you so
lots to talk about uh this evening
um why don't we start with the uh strike
action that is coming up Christina a
huge amount of it by all accounts and
there's a sort of last bid effort to try
and halt at least some of it is it
working
no and according to this story there
isn't much of a last minute effort to
try and halt it um the allegation is
that Steve Bartley the health secretary
isn't really engaging with the issue I
mean he certainly is in trying to do
what he can to make sure that the
strikes affect patients as little as
possible but they will affect patients
of course enormously but what he's not
doing according to this piece is making
any offers which I think it sounds as if
um NHS workers and uh and union leaders
are quite surprised by I mean the
Scottish government did make an offer
which was accepted uh which was in fact
below inflation well for Sumner for some
lower paid workers it was above
inflation but what's indicated in this
piece is that a below inflation offer
would at least be a starting point I
think possibly the trouble is and I
think you know the nurses have the
nurses and health workers have this
empathy of the nation 65 of people I
think support them in the strike and I
support them in this strike but they are
asking for an enormous pay ride so I can
see why it's difficult for the
government to know where to meet that
but they should certainly be negotiating
because this will be disastrous for many
many people and people will die as a
result of this we have to be clear about
that
I mean this uh um uh offer that has been
put down is based on the recommendations
of the NHS pay review bodies Nick
Christina which is an independent
organization
uh well I wasn't aware that an offer had
well I mean the offer is something like
three percent yeah
you're up to three percent well given
that given that inflation is currently
at least 10 clearly that is insulting
and we already know that since 2010
nurses and uh and health workers but
nurses in particular have already
suffered a real terms enormous pay cut
so three percent in the current climate
is insulting and I can absolutely see
why nurses wouldn't even think of
considering an offer like that clearly
the government has to go in much much
higher than that and I'm pretty baffled
as to why they haven't because this is
going to be very bad PR for them because
the public support the the health
workers Ali what do you make of this
story in the Observer and the strike
situation in general
well look it's a winter of discontent
and it's been uh building up for some
time and when you've had a situation
where real wages uh have been falling
for a lot of people in the public sector
over the past decade you're going to
have problems and there was always going
to be a revolution of some kind and it
looks like on the back of kovid uh this
has triggered it we all clapped for
nurses on Thursdays uh I have a lot of
time obviously for nurses my mother's
been an NHS doctor for 40 years you've
got problems across the piece the GPS
want to have a fewer hours that the
nurses are striking teachers as well
personal workers uh rail workers RIT
Lodge I think the issue here is that the
Royal College of Nursing which is
striking for the first time in its
history there's often 19 now whilst
Christine is absolutely right 65 of the
public support the nurses and I also
empathize with exactly where they're
coming from of course I do 19 is not
realistic given the fact that we've got
a 400 billion overhang from covert and
2.7 trillion pounds of public debt in a
rising interest rate environment with
inflation 11 or I mean it's just not
practical so if they put something more
reasonable on the table there might be a
discussion but this is completely beyond
the pale and unrealistic so what needs
to happen is both sides need to come
together
Steve Barkley's a very he's a smart
dedicated hard-working sensible person
I'm sure that there will be he hasn't
been willing to get involved directly so
far because he's left it to the
independent pay review buddy I think
there's got to be some room for
negotiation somewhere in the meantime
what they're now trying to do is to try
and find contingency plans where they're
going to be getting uh pharmacies to do
more work uh with respect to GPS and
trying to put in other contingencies but
Christina is right this is going to
affect people's Health we've already had
excess deaths uh witty and balance came
out with a report this week that showed
that excess death surprise surprise are
going to be persisting for some time on
the back of lockdowns which fine we
understand why they happen but the
effects of those both economic and
health are going to be persisting and
this is not going to help the situation
we need all sent all sites to see scents
and the nurses to make a practical
reasonable request as well on their side
yeah and the window of opportunity is uh
is getting smaller and smaller isn't it
by the day as we head towards Christmas
okay let's move on to a story on the
front of the Sunday Telegraph Christina
um Robert jenwick the immigration
Minister saying it's very hard to see
how albanians should be able to claim
asylum in this country when they come
from a safe country and saying that we
should ban albanians from claiming
Asylum what do you make of this
well actually very unusually
um I'm tempted to agree with him on this
I don't approve of the Rwanda policy and
I think that Savannah Braverman has so
far been an absolutely disgraceful Home
Secretary not least for breaching
knowingly and repeatedly the ministerial
code and I found it breathtaking that
she was restored to her job after
breaching the ministerial code however
there is something going on with
albanians where a very high proportion I
mean a kind of significant percentage of
Albanian young men and children who may
or may not be children are traveling
here in the hope of a better life and
you can't blame them for that and there
is great poverty in Albania it's a poor
country and why wouldn't they want to
come here but this is not they are not
you know it's not illegal for them to be
economic migrants and they are clogging
up the system for people fleeing from
water on countries like Syria and
Afghanistan and it's simply not fair so
and Albania is a safe country it may not
be for all its women or children but
generally speaking it is for men so I do
have some sympathy with this View and I
do think that probably albanians coming
here should be fast-tracked into a
system where they are instantly returned
to Albania and decisions are made very
quickly and um maybe should be treated
differently but I support this
interesting uh in this island because it
says Sweden's already set the precedent
by treating Albania as a safe State uh
from which Asylum applications are
treated as unfounded um Ali I want to
move on because we're we're running
short of time we've got a lot of stories
to cover
um it's another immigration story of A
Sort isn't it on the front of Reserve
this time uh concerning afghans
well yeah this is this uh Afghan
resettlement scheme which was meant to
be the case where if you couldn't make
it out of that airport and that haven't
that happened over those few days over
that weekend where the foreign secretary
was on holiday and then ran to rush back
and it was all pretty mismanaged quite
frankly I mean I know Ben Wallace did
his best but it was a pretty unedifying
spectacle from our side having used
these people uh to try and get what we
wanted uh during that uh Afghan walk
against uh against the Taliban so these
people were told that there would be a
route out for them if they applied for
asylum in this country and the reality
is that since this scheme started uh in
January not a single person has come
over and in fact uh we're led to believe
according to this story there are only
eight people in the foreign office that
are designated to deal with these claims
where there was hundreds dealing with
the claims of ukrainians so what it
shows is that if you're an Afghan and
you're being asked for your support by
the British government and the U.S
forces you're basically going to be hung
out to dry so next next time we go into
these kind of situations and I'm not
saying that the word Afghanistan was not
warranted obviously Al-Qaeda were taking
Refuge there and and all the rest of it
there was a rationale for it unlike Iraq
by the way uh then you're going to have
to question whether people are actually
going to trust you in the same way that
your allies are also going to trust you
when you leave in a chap as a Havoc man
wreaking havoc everywhere they're also
going to wonder whether you can actually
be relied upon uh to be in there for the
Long Haul so a very very bad look I
think uh for the government okay um
let's talk a bit about strep a before
the break uh because obviously it's it's
concerning a lot of people especially
parents of young children Christina and
the express goes into quite a lot of
detail about it
um the NHS is on alert
um not helped of course by by this
crisis with with nurses going uh
potentially on on strike
no I mean it's awful and for uh the the
parents of the children who have died I
mean that it's hard to imagine a greater
tragedy to live through it's not exactly
clear why it's spreading um one
suggestion is that children's immunity
is lower uh redu greatly reduced by the
fact that there's been there have been
all these lockdowns and I suppose that
was an inevitable consequence and of
course there are enormous waiting lists
in the NHS and it is quite hard to get
doctor's appointments and uh and and
also there is um resistance to
antibiotics but it's very very worrying
and of course strike action from nurses
or any other healthcare workers is
unlikely to help in this situation and
although there is talk of training up
pharmacists to prescribe antibiotics
um you know that doesn't sound like a
very foolproof system so something to be
anxious about and we can just hope that
this doesn't grow incrementally because
it would be absolutely tragic if it did
yeah we saw only seeing a spy can't we
Ali and it is important to reiterate
it's very rare that anyone dies from
this but clearly it is very concerning
um and it is something that teachers
parents doctors really need to be alert
to because you need to get the treatment
to Children quickly and then they're
fine but you do need to get it to them
that's right so you're looking at uh a
redness rash uh sore throat all of these
things you also need to focus on
cleanliness that's what we're being told
but again when you've had a situation
where we have been in lockdown these
things are unfortunately going to happen
because we have less immunity built up
in the system and obviously it's
absolutely tragic and heartbreaking for
the families of the six um young people
that have died of kids that have died
here really really very very sad and
deep and there's some arguments about
whether antibiotics in certain cases
should have been given further but I
mean it's not exactly clear as to what
could have been done but that's one
argument that's been made and look all
precautions should be taken and people
are seeing these signs they should seek
help hello again part two of The Press
preview Christina and Ali still with us
and Christine we're calling to
tomorrow's tabloids there's only two
stories in town uh the footy and the
royal family look at the front of the
mirror if you would for us utterly
explosive is how they are describing
this uh Netflix documentary by Harry and
Megan
yes well I mean I just wish whatever
happened or whatever they felt happened
I really wish they would shut up about
it this is Harry and Megan and their
sense of deep victimhood relating to
Megan's time in the Royal household now
I do think that at the time some of the
media coverage he got was racist and
unpleasant I would say it's not yet
clear whether she was treated in a
racist Way by anybody in the royal
family and they certainly made those
allegations on Oprah Winfrey which were
deeply upsetting for the queen and
obviously this week we've had an example
of a lady in waiting or whatever they're
called These Days who did treat a guest
in a way that certainly seemed extremely
racist so I wouldn't rule that out but
whether or not there were any racist uh
whether or not there was any unfair or
racist Behavior what is evident is that
there are many people in the world
suffering an awful lot more than Harry
and Megan in their multi-million pound
mansion with their multi-million dollar
Netflix and Spotify deals and I think it
really is undignified and Unbecoming for
them to be going on and on and on about
the ways in which they have suffered
clearly in order to enhance their brand
and make money and I think it's going to
be very difficult for William and Kate
I'm sure there will be all kinds of
allegations made that it will be hard
for them to rebut but in the long term
their brand will fade because there is a
limit to the number of times you can say
poor me poor me poor me from a
multi-million pound home so I I really
hope that this Fades eventually but I
think it's going to be very difficult
for the royal family yeah ali um front
of the Sunday Telegraph similar story uh
case and Megan pitted against each other
in Netflix series
yeah look I think Christina summed it up
very well I mean the business model for
uh Harry and Megan is the monetization
of grievance or alleged grievance uh and
that's the game they're playing and I
think Christina's right uh this uh film
will play for a certain while and then
people are going to get tired of it look
don't get me wrong I enjoy Megan's
podcasts as much as the next person I
particularly enjoyed the one with Mariah
Carey about divas that was great I wish
Megan would focus on her bid to run for
U.S president which I hope she'll Mount
rather than engaging in this sort of
unedifying spectacle it does seem to me
that they are trying to bring the royal
family down it's deeply unnecessary uh
unhelpful and look I I always thought
that Harry was a perfectly decent guy I
I think he being withdrawn of his uh
stripped of his uh military affiliations
and you know leaving the Army I thought
would have had an impact on him he seems
to be happy enough but is this really a
way of like going about your business I
mean you've been major point on Oprah
Winfrey do we really need to have the
spectacle we've also got his book to
look forward to coming out next year as
well spare yeah um I'm going to stick
with you Ali to talk about the football
because Christine has already admitted
to me in the break that she's not
watching any of it um apart from when
she's forced to by her partner so let's
uh let's sum things up Ali it's going to
be uh exciting evening tomorrow England
have scored their most goals ever in a
tournament group stage so far nine are
you hopeful tomorrow and Sunday people
says yes we can
yes I am hopeful but England need to
rise to the occasion they had a really
great start against Iran uh that was a
very good match uh and they also
performed against uh Wales but they
weren't so good against the US so they
need to keep that standard high and
they're up against a pretty handy team I
mean look they're lucky that sadio Mane
is not playing the Bayern Munich Ford
he's injured so that's an advantage uh
for uh England but they still have some
very good players Senegal you've got to
remember these are the champions of the
Africa Cup of Nations they beat Egypt
which is very handy team
um with Mo Salah and they've got good
players in there they've got um eduard
Mendy and uh Kelly body from from
Chelsea so these guys are good and
England's gonna have to be on top four
but the tournament's wide open I watched
the matches today I thought Argentina
were decent uh and the Netherlands as
well but you know there's all to play
for it I don't think there's any
standout yet Christine got this
tournament so no Christina who do you
think should play up from the news and
stay on the bench
well all I know is that Marcus rashford
is a very very nice young man and as far
as I can tell quite a good footballer so
I think he should be there all the time
well said excellent thank you both very
much